all right guys you want to go on a
camping trip
yeah all right let's do it and uh i
brought chicken
what
there it is let's see how's she doing
looks like she's doing good no problems
make sure there's no raccoon or anything
living in here we're back
at the log cabin we've been working on
this thing
all year she's beautiful and she's
holding up really
really well so pleased uh it's late
today so we're gonna get in there we're
gonna cook up some food we're gonna get
camp all set up tomorrow we're gonna
have a lot of fun
all right guys looks pretty good in here
yeah all right guys should we get our
beds made up
so there's not quite enough room for all
three boys and myself to sleep on the
bed in the cabin
so tommy and jacob are gonna sleep
inside and me and nate are gonna sleep
out under the stars
so that should be kind of fun as long as
it doesn't rain
all right we built this log cabin to
keep us warm in the winter but there's
one
downside building a fire in that stove
in the summertime
is brutal it gets so warm in there
so we need to build a fire pit outside
so that we can cook and have fires
outside without roasting to death
hey boys do you want hamburgers for
dinner yeah now listen i'm gonna need to
get a fire going can you guys gather up
all the firewood you can
there get go
all right i've got my blast match here
and i've got some cedar bark
and uh we're gonna try to lighten up
this fire
[Music]
my pieces in
the spot above the fire is mostly clear
but there's a few limbs we got to clear
out
not a big deal now because these green
leaves will just shrivel up and die they
won't burn
but in the fall when they're dead it
will become a problem
hey
yeah just keep sawing up some wood for
our breakfast fire and just stack it up
against the log cabin okay
come sit in my chair with me all right
guys let me tell you a story about
a famous hockey player who learned to
golf
his name was happy gilmore
you know we look like moonshiners
drinking white liquid from a jug out
here in the virginia backwoods don't we
well listen guys you getting hungry yeah
you want me to make hamburgers
daddy took the hot stick that you were
using
[Music]
zach fowler from the youtube channel
fowler's makery and mischief
gave me a bottle of his signature series
hot sauce when we were up in maine so
i think i might use it on my hamburger
today try to season it it's actually
pretty good hot sauce
[Music]
some golf games that's an onion
i love onions i love onions too
yeah there's a big old crane fly keeps
bugging me
watch your fingers watch your fingers
but that's a tomato if you want to try a
bit of tomato
try that
they seem like a fish you like the
tomato
that's exactly what we're going to do
who wants the first hamburger i do i do
me
okay yeah those are the dogs
you want the second one okay all right
jake there's one for you
you guys got that peanut butter on your
hamburger
madness coleslaw and hamburger
dinner of champions right there you guys
you like those hamburgers
yeah yeah yeah all those are good
i'm glad you like it so happy gilmore's
arch enemy
was a man named shooter mcgavin where i
said you're eating dinner and tommy goes
hey is that a bird's nest in there
look at this
that might be a mouse nest yeah i think
that's a mouse desk but look at that
that's great tinder
i'm gonna take that and use that for
tinder keep that in my tinder bag
oh you get ready for bed okay guys it's
time for bed
all right guys hey tommy get in your
sleeping bag buddy we got a big day
tomorrow we're gonna do lots of fun
things
you guys need to get a good night's rest
good night guys
well it's late and the boys are asleep
so i'm going to try to catch some z's
under the stars here but
i have two two small problems one i
accidentally poked a small hole in my
air mattress and it's slowly deflating
and will leave me flat on the ground
two apparently the ground is covered in
large spiders
many of whom are covered with little
tiny baby spiders on their back
and they keep crawling all over my
sleeping bag so
it's going to be an interesting night
come on lady take your kids elsewhere
come on yeah yeah yeah off my back i'm
still gonna get covered in spiders
tonight
oh well
you warm now
nathan and jacob are you guys awake
good morning
no that's that's never happened well i
actually know something that's never had
10 children
to bring a bunch of stuff for the french
toast so we're instead we're just
eyes here
all right here's my new camping recipe
we have a slice of toasted chocolate
brioche
and i've got a go-gurt here and
we are just squeezing some yogurt on
that
that's really good
[Music]
all right
[Music]
salt and pepper on a sunny-side up egg
oh it's so great
um i've got a few chores to do around
the cabin here and the boys of course
want to wander around the woods and play
so i've got each one of them have
walkie-talkie
and this way we can stay in touch can
you guys hear me
[Music]
okay
number one on our agenda today is
exploring a nearby river we're going to
see if we can catch any fish and maybe
do a little swimming you guys excited
we'll see what happens okay
big spider web in my face
yeah i can hear the river
look at this guys is this a cool
swimming hole
daddy what's going right now
that's a little cold oh look at this
uh oh what uh-oh what tick
oh that looks like a deer tick too here
hey everyone look at your legs for ticks
so i got both my rods sitting in a bite
alarm i got a little bit of fish
uh out there and we're gonna just see
what happens you want to go down in
there you can go
go down there
let's see oh this is cold
there's a swimming nade
[Music]
that is a perfect tree for jumping in
the water
oh portia jake just got a shower
guys this is just like the perfect tree
for jumping in
look at this yes
this is like a perfect diving board
right here yeah like it's deep
quick oh
look at that swimming tommy
[Music]
how are you i'm doing it
i'm doing it you guys should totally
jump off this this is gonna be great
it's not that high i know it's miserable
it breathes from its bottom
are you done
all right buddy show me your ninja move
i think this is the perfect diving and
swimming hole the only problem is
it's only like 70 degrees right now and
uh the water
the water isn't that warm
[Music]
oh do i dare you to swim yeah i dare you
to swim
look at jk swim look how far he's going
oh nate i'm proud of you
[Laughter]
oh look at jake it's going to start
[Music]
he's even swimming up against the
current that's pretty good oh
that's as far as that's
[Applause]
[Music]
jacob i am impressed at what a good
swimmer you are here hold up your hand
real quick
show me how how old are you
that's a that's a wobbly three okay
let's go get you warmed up
there's a path over here let me get you
up into the sunshine
let you warm up a little bit okay dad
nathan was pushing me in
so watch out for the poison ivy that's
poison ivy that's poison ivy that's
poison ivy that's poison ivy
that's poison ivy poison ivy
everywhere you go in virginia just crazy
amounts of poison ivy
just walking barefoot through the poison
ivy
no problem oh this dirt's warm jake you
want to stand on this dirt
right here are you guys cold you want to
head back
all right let's do it well we only
soaked the rods for a few minutes but
didn't get any bites so we'll have to
try it again a little bit later
oh guys i can see the log cabin we're
saved
all right we made it back you guys want
some watermelon
yeah yeah let's eat some watermelon
how can you feel so weird daddy oh
you're
getting this one tom is that a big
enough piece for you
whoa you guys like that watermelon
yeah is watermelon like your favorite
thing yeah
nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nice shirt
there jacob
if you guys want outdoor boys t-shirts
and other merchandise check out the link
below
if you guys haven't seen them already
check out our two winter camping videos
where me and my boys we built that log
cabin using only hand tools
it took us a lot of work and made for
some really great videos i'll put links
down in the video description below
also guys make sure to click subscribe
so you can check out our other
adventures we got coming up because we
have a ton of them
we've got some great building projects
some forging projects some
big epic road trips and travel adventure
videos
we're gonna be camping on a volcano um
we've got
all sorts of things going on and you
guys won't want to miss it
so make sure to click subscribe and
check us out every saturday morning
thanks for watching guys we hope you
enjoyed this video
[Music]
good job guys if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching what happens if you
leave your camera
with kids
what what what